[Music]
on today's show we talked to a young man
whose surprise
girlfriend is pregnant and he doesn't
know what to do next we also talk with
somebody dealing with suicidal thoughts
in dealing with their own family trauma
and a husband with ptsd
stay tuned
hey what's up good folks this is john
with the dr john delony show
pull up a seat at the bar grab something
to eat that's not
gross bring something good something you
can share
everybody's welcome
tired of people defining their
communities by who they all hate
together
who who thinks differently than they do
has life experiences that are different
than they are
and it's time to start bringing people
together and that's what we do on the
show
i don't care who you are i don't care
where you're from i don't care what
you're going through
in a world gone mad we're gonna take
your calls on mental health
on relationships on your marriage on
your dating on kids all of it
and we're gonna walk together to help
figure this out and in the process
i hope to teach you how to reconsider
challenges right how to reconsider
relationships i hope
i hope that we can teach one another how
to say i'm sorry
how to say man i thought i was right on
that and i was super wrong and i'm gonna
do this one again
i hope we can teach each other humility
and teach each other how to do the next
right thing so i'm so glad that you
called it's awesome
if you want to be on the show if you
want to be on the show give me a shout
at 1-844-693-3291 that's 1-844-693-3291
or go to johndaloni.com
show fill out the form it goes to kelly
and she creates the
shows from there and so i feel like it's
important to start the show with
this is my confession
i just need to be honest and open this
is it no usher
i think that was incredible usher i do
like usher i'm impressed
okay good i appreciate that this is my
confession this is how today started out
i woke up super early started my morning
routine went through all my crazy stuff
i went and sat down in my little
basement on my
little rug and did my gratitude journal
all that stuff
copied my thoughts for the day then i
went and
worked out and went for a run it was
like 35 degrees in
in nashville this morning so i went for
a run then i got done i didn't even come
inside i went straight and sat in the
cold tub and it was
super cold it was good i went upstairs
saw the kids got ready for
work i'm in the middle of an
intermittent fast i wanted to
to fast through lunch so i had made some
more coffee
and then i thought no i'm just gonna
have one of these little
i don't know packaged keto bars
and then that led to a second packaged
keto bar at which point i was like well
i'm already into it so
i'm gonna dump some really fancy some of
dr asks ash
josh axe some of his ancient nutrition
keto collagen powder whatever
shenanigans
into my coffee
that devolved and then about half hour
later i was sitting there
working on some work stuff while i just
crushed a sleeve of um
would call them thin mints dude i
dominated thin mints
then i got up and i went into my bedroom
to grab something
and my wife had some of those samoa
stuff which evidently they make with
um caramel and crack cocaine so i had
some of those and then i felt bad so i
went back to
dude today just it devolved it started
so good
i fell off the wagon i didn't fall off i
parked the wagon and i got out and i
laid underneath it and it ran over me a
few times and so then i had to get back
up and i just had to tell everybody the
truth on
the show i'm person too and i screwed up
today but i'm just gonna get up shake it
off and move on
and hey here's the thing that old that
old
meditation quote from back in the day
every breath has a chance to start over
i may start over till this evening and
just go ahead and finish today with a
bowl of ice cream or something i don't
know i gotta
i gotta be better than that but i
already feel like
a box of crap on a stick and so we're
gonna just power through today we're
gonna get it done all right let's go
let's go to the phones let's go to
patrick in oklahoma city
what's up brother patrick how are we
doing hey dr john nice talking to you
can you hear me yes sir i can how about
you man
oh i'm you know doing well good deal so
um hey hold on what'd you have for
breakfast today
please please tell me girl scout cookies
uh
what is this called um a honey bun so
just as fast
patrick can you totally redeem yourself
i don't even know we're talking that's
awesome good for you patrick you just
made my whole day
listen we got to be better than that
right yes okay exactly
all right tomorrow we're back on the
wagon so what's up brother how can i
help yeah so um
i let's see i'm with a girlfriend of
almost three years
and we just found out that we were
pregnant all right how old are you man
um almost 23. almost 23. okay cool
and we're freaking out
you say that so joyfully as though if i
don't continue to laugh my way through
this i will
spontaneously combust is that where
you're at yeah yeah
man all right so she with you right now
uh
no she i'm i'm on my lunch break right
now okay
all right so 23 you've been with the
same girl for three years
and now y'all are having a kid how far
along are you
um just a month or two really early on
okay so you haven't even got past so
you're just at four or five weeks six
seven weeks
right okay very cool all right so you're
freaking out what does that even mean
man that means something different to
everybody what does freaking out mean
yeah so basically whenever we took the
test we
just were like in disbelief like okay
this
is actually happening and um we're kind
of just
at a kind of loss um at
what to do next honestly um we've been
doing a lot of talking on like
whether we should keep it or not put up
for adoption
we just don't know really where to begin
so we're
looking at guidance for that gotcha so
three years with the same person
is this somebody you're going to spend
the rest of your life with uh that's a
plan yeah
i mean you're three years in bro you
know all right
[Laughter]
i know it yeah yes yes yeah we're
talking about
marriage of course okay so what about
having a babies freaking you out
a simple fact of being a dad and also
tell my parents
what do you do for a living man uh i'm a
banker
at one of the local banks here in
oklahoma okay so you're a banker did you
go to college
um i am taking a hiatus right now okay
that was awesome management's
restructuring man all right so you're
taking a hiatus all you have to say is
no i'm not going to school you don't
even have to explain it to me man
um i like how you have a built-in fancy
fancy excuse for no i dropped out for
right now but i'll go back at some point
hopefully
all right all right so and what's your
wife do man our girlfriend sorry
whatever girlfriend future wife uh she's
a manager at a clothing store
manager at a clothing store okay so when
you
number one take your parents off the
thing you're 23 dude you're a banker
what does that even mean by the way are
you a loan officer are you a teller
um basically teller type do you use
big language to make people think you're
more than you are
no not really because you said you're a
banker and
um hiatus those are big like
you're a pretty good guy huh
i don't like to talk about why not
myself honestly
main main thing you just called the show
with about a million listeners to it
like uh right i know so why
why are you self-deprecating
not in a funny way but in like the
serious way why are you undermining
yourself
um i think that more or less just has to
do with
um i mean honestly i have no clue
honestly i'm just trying to
come up with something on the spot but
i'm not sure why does a 23 year old guy
with a full-time job
care where his mom and dad thinks right
now are they gonna ground you what are
they gonna do you still live with them
no no no we're we're uh living together
okay am i girlfriend okay so y'all are
been together three years
you're playing married on tv
and now you have a
are pregnant she's pregnant
what about this freaks you out other
than
see i'm what i'm getting at like you've
got your
no 23 year old has their life together
but for a vast majority of them
you're on your way man you got a job you
are learning a trade
in a a mad house of an industry right
your wife or your fiance keep calling
your wife your girlfriend is
a manager at a clothing store y'all are
living together i mean
tell get something deeper man because
you're not selling me on why this isn't
yeah this is out of order
yeah this isn't in our plan yeah is it
gonna make for hard conversations with
our family yeah
but you're not selling me on why this is
worth freaking out other than yeah this
is different than we thought
and now we're in it yeah right yeah i
think that's the main thing
is just um about having those uh hard
conversations and
um really kind of going
going from there yeah and like what to
do next and
everything like that it's just also just
everything sped up like a million miles
really quick yeah dude okay yeah so
i'm gonna give you the opposite i waited
my wife and i dated for off and on for
five years
then we were married for eight years
before we had
our son and i was not ready for it then
i was dramatic and it was like oh my
gosh
what what's and i had all this drama and
all this
i'm not ready and shut up dude like oh
and that's me telling myself to shut up
right
so all right i don't know very many
people
who are ever quote unquote ready and if
they think they're ready there's
they're super not because you can have
no idea what's coming right
both on the hey this is
more exhausting than we thought this
would be more expensive than we thought
and more importantly on the other side
in a million years i would not have
waited eight years to have kids had i
known
what it would do for my capacity to love
to to experience love to
experience parts of myself that i didn't
know existed
to fall deeper in love with the person
i'd been with for what 12
13 years up to that point had no idea
and it was this idea
like this master idea that was life
isn't about your plans it's about who
you
are what you do and who you choose to be
when life happens at you
right right so you probably had when
were you thinking about getting married
did y'all like talked about it and you
have some
dream schedule yeah yeah we
we did a lot of talking um before
before this and we're thinking about
getting married um
about another one or two years out okay
um
and having kids three to five years out
all right dude you just got half a
decade back congratulations right
that's awesome and so
here's the thing i get the freak out
part i get that i'm not i'm i'm
laughing with you dude i get that like
everything just got turned upside down
it got
life got real serious all of a sudden
right and
also tell you're 23 and it's it's time
to be
for life to be serious okay right never
ever ever make
massive decisions against a hard
conversation
okay what i mean by that is
too many people make themselves
clinically insane
clinically insane they shorten their
lifespan
they endure pain and trauma for
years less than that they
they endure less than a great sex life
with their with their partner they
endure less than a good job
because they are scared of having a hard
conversation and they just punt and
punt and punt and punt and so i want you
to flip this around on you
this can be not in your plan
but one of the most extraordinary things
that ever happens to you
my brother you're going to be a dad
and there is no greater honor on planet
earth than to be a dad
none there's no harder thing to do i'm
being a husband's pretty hard
but being a dad is the hardest greatest
thing you will ever ever do
right it's it is the top of the mountain
man
it is and you've got a lot to learn and
a lot to grow up on
i want you to get um this is not a
decision that you
and let me let me back out when you say
you're like you're putting all these
options on the table
like be honest are you all just talking
because this is a crazy season
are you probably gonna have this kid
like where are you guys
yeah um that's a great question thanks
for asking that um
we kind of were talking about not having
it
mainly due to the timing of it and
everything like that
yeah but and there's just this like
ever aching like echo in the like the
back of my head and my heart and
everything like that that's just
basically saying
but what if you know that what if thing
is just like just driving me and saying
like what if in the future now we won't
be able to have kicks what if
um xyz it's just been
really really heavy where is she
we're on the same page of basically not
having it
but i'm just afraid for
what the future will hold and what
things will happen are possible things
um will happen like will it
impact our relationship will it impact
um
her chances of getting pregnant in the
future you know all of that stuff
um whenever we quote unquote are already
a half kegs
and i know that if you know i say hey
what if we have the kid um completely
and you know it'll be ours won't be
anyone else's we won't put up for
adoption or anything like that
i know that she'll be like i know that
she would say
okay i'm okay with that um
she's kind of indifferent on what to do
and that's just kind of
the most nerve-wracking thing about it i
have a hard time believing that she's
indifferent
yeah are you can i ask you this are you
hard to be
firm around no i'm i'm one of the
most outgoing people that um like i've
been told that
is like people can't come to me for
things that
um like that are
different or weird or a weird situation
i can kind of help point them in the
right direction on okay
that's what to do next and
but hey i do that for a living brother
and i've got people in my life that do
that for me
because it's hard to do with a mirror
right right
so say that out loud i'm gonna be a dad
i'm gonna be a dad
what did you feel man
besides the existential terror that
every new almost soon-to-be dad is gonna
feel
i feel whenever i say i'm going to be a
dad
i i don't know i kind of feel of course
scared
but more or less just like okay
we'll kind of figure it out more or less
awesome all right so here's the deal
everything in your life when you have
this kid
i hear it in you man i hear it in you
when you have this kid
everything's going to change and you are
going to find yourself walking six
inches taller
you're gonna find yourself exhausted
you're gonna find yourself thinking i'm
probably gonna go back to school or i'm
gonna get more hours
all those things are gonna change right
there's a before and after
there you are at that point now i
want you uh but uh but before i move on
but dude let me just tell you let me
tell you
and you're not asking my opinion i'm
just giving it to you
i can't tell you what it's like
to hold that kid i can't tell you
what it's like when that tiny little
hand grabs your finger and squeezes so
hard that you think your finger's gonna
come off
i can't tell you what it's like for my
friends who've adopted when they bring
their kid home for the first time
and you sit down and that in that glow
of
terror and joy and love that you didn't
know you were capable of in fear
and you look at the person you're
married to and you're like what did we
do
and here we are all of that okay
i can also hear it in you you want to be
confident
so hard any which way and you're not and
that freaks you out you're probably a
confident guy who's just taking a hiatus
right
you're a confident guy and then suddenly
this happened
i would be willing to bet my car and
it's not nice right so you're not going
to get a lot out of it if i'm wrong
i would bet that your wife your
girlfriend god i keep calling your wife
sorry brother
that's not i'm not trying to be
subliminal or anything like i'm trying
to be tricky i just keep calling that
um i can't imagine that your
girlfriend's indifferent
yeah she has to have some feelings and
thoughts on this that either she is
uncomfortable saying out loud to you
or she's afraid of what you're gonna say
or
if she is inside of her so
thrilled to be like we're gonna have oh
my gosh
but if she's not getting that from you
she's gonna soft play it and
downplay it and lo low drive it because
she's worried does that make sense
yeah and so if you can go home tonight
and hold both of your hands and look her
in the eye and say
i'm gonna be a dad
like we're doing this right
and you can make a journey to nashville
from from
oklahoma we'll marry you over here like
anthony o'neil is an
ordained minister of some sort he'll
marry you here right we'll do it for
free
and you know what i'm saying like let's
get this done and
we're going to figure this out and then
we're going to have a conversation with
our parents
and they're going to be like oh my gosh
and they're going to be that way for
about two seconds
and then they're going to realize we're
about to be grandparents and then the
game's on
right and then everybody rallies up and
you're going to get more nonsense advice
and more like well you know your [ __ ]
all that stuff that's just part of the
deal
but before if if that's not in the plan
if you are uncomfortable that i want you
to you
and her go talk to a professional
therapist
tomorrow okay
this is red alert for your relationship
this is red alert for your mental health
for her mental health this is
red alert for everybody okay yeah and
they will give you some tools on how to
move forward
how to have these conversations with
people that you're scared to have these
conversations with
how to wrap your head around hey dude
we're gonna have we're gonna have a
child
right we're in this now
but i want you to hear me say you're not
crazy for
thinking everything went sideways it is
it did
i don't want you to think you're crazy
because
you guys had a plan and suddenly your
plans just went up in smoke and now
you've got some major things
one of which is we've created a human
right i also
want you to realize you're 23 you're
gonna have to have start having hard
conversations that's a part of your life
from this point forward
this is going to be the hard
conversation to have right i also want
you
to um
not minimize this one awesome thing
brother you're about to be a dad
you're about to be a dad your
girlfriend's about to be a mom
and this is big big stuff right thank
you for calling
you're right to freak out now go make
the right decisions
on getting the tools you need to go be a
great mom to be a great dad
to go be a great husband go get
connected here thank you for the call
let me know how it goes whenever you
have your conversations i want to hear
how that goes
and what the next steps are going to be
thanks for your call patrick all right
let's go to
victoria in nashville tennessee victoria
what's going on
i'm going well how about you john i am
going well
as well as you can go right with a
breakfast of girl scout cookies so how
how can i help hey what did you have for
breakfast
uh i can't remember that's what i'm
doing yeah
i know which i have a baby i can't
remember what i ate
an hour ago well played well played
well played all right so what's up
so i should preface this call by saying
i'm not
suicidal
i'm not laughing i i don't know who i'm
not laughing at you laughing with you
like man no it's funny remember no it's
not funny i'm just the number of times
i've had that a conversation prefaced
with that in my career has been a lot
and it always
the follow-up is here we go all right so
i got my uh
i got my i don't know my
hard conversation held on let's do this
all right so you're not suicidal but
but i have a lot of suicidal thoughts
while i'm doing just super mundane
things and they come
just super random like i'll be driving
and i'm thinking i just so badly want to
just swerve my car and crash oh and i
need to pick up peanut butter
yeah okay so give me another example
yeah
so sometimes when i'm doing dishes i'll
be putting them away
and i'll pick up a knife and i just
think like
okay what if i just stabbed myself with
this right now like everything would be
over and done with and i'd be okay with
that and then i put it away
and like feed my baby okay it's just
super random
and yeah what can i do to
control that or like would that classify
me as suicidal like what
i'm just i need help number one
thank you for trusting me with this this
one um
like beyond like i hear i hear you're
somebody that approaches hard
conversations with laughter right
i'm i'm a similar way are there moments
when this has scared you
oh absolutely yes okay all right so
uh transitioning from me laughing and
carrying on and
understanding like these are this is a
scary thing so
um one i want to tell you i'm grateful
for yours brave for you to call
most people in your situation that i've
worked with over the years
man they think they start to think
they're crazy right they think they're
nuts and they think i'm wrong with them
and that if they will just speak this
out loud someone's going to take away
their babies someone's going to
institutionalize them or whatever is
next right
so it's brave that you called and i
appreciate that
when you i'm going to walk you through
something i'm going to start this whole
thing off with
the idea that you have these intrusive
thoughts is the way the nerds say them
right
so these are lightning bolts that just
shoot into your mind they just
pop in there and you will go whoa right
that's not nuts happens to everybody
intrusive thoughts about self-harm
particularly in moments where you could
actually do it like it's not like you're
just walking around the thing at target
you're like man if i had a knife i could
just stab myself
it's when you're holding it right i'm
gonna tell you those aren't abnormal but
they're not
great right they're not healthy and so
i want to get some more information from
you so where if you had to just
mine your life right mind the life is
victoria
where are they from how long have they
have they happened
where do you think these have shown up
ah that's a great question so i was
actually thinking about this the other
day
and they've been going on for as long as
i can remember the
first time that i can actually remember
i was probably like
nine or ten like it like the thought
just popped in my head but i kept it to
myself because i'm like oh everybody
must have these thoughts
it wasn't until recently that they
started getting worse and i actually
started like formulating oh what if i
did
exactly this like that i started
thinking maybe i should talk to somebody
yeah yeah so how old your baby
she is one one okay did you have any
postpartum with this baby
i probably i just was never treated
okay okay so tell me about um growing up
did you experience trauma as a kid
yes um my mom is an alcoholic okay
um some verbal and sexual abuse as well
okay um just a lot of things that no kid
should go through i went through you're
exactly right yeah
has when you were pregnant when you
found out you were pregnant and over the
arc of your pregnancy
did that stuff circle up more than it
normally has
no just say old same old were you
excited to be pregnant
yeah yes my husband she was she was
planned
so we were very happy when we found out
that we were pregnant very cool
all right so in in your like let's
i'm just gonna pick one up where do you
work yes
okay so you're at work how do you handle
a a stressful customer or if your boss
has to have a hard conversation with you
and have to talk to you like how do you
handle that
so i actually just started my job
yesterday so i haven't had to deal with
that
you cope with challenges it really just
depends on what the challenge is i try
to remain calm
but sometimes i just i get so angry
and i just have to walk away okay like
i'm just not able to
to hide how upset i am that they're
upset with me
have you ever tried to hurt yourself
before yes
okay have you ever made a suicide
attempt before
kind of okay what's that mean um
one time i did actually crash my car
okay intentionally
yes and no i was going 55 i saw gravel
and i just slammed on my brakes on
gravel gravel and twisted my wheel
potentially like swerving it like i
don't know if i had the intention of
like
doing any harm but i would consider that
yeah
yeah have you ever yeah have you ever um
have you ever struggled with uh
disordered eating or
self-cutting yourself no no okay
have you ever been diagnosed with any
mental health issues
so i've been to a couple of counselors
through the years and i
i just i've never liked any of them one
said that i was bipolar
another said that i was depressed
another said
that i just needed to practice gratitude
and geez
so i just just just light a candle and
take a warm bath that'll fix it right
god almighty just all over the place so
i just i don't
i didn't trust any of those because it
would be one session and they're like
oh you're you're obviously bipolar and
i'm like but am i though
yeah so tell me about your friends your
community that you hang out with people
that you go to when things get
bananas uh so i
we've actually just moved to nashville
not too long ago
with kovid we really haven't like been
able to
hang out with a whole lot of people but
we are in a church back up before
becca before nashville did you have a um
a gang where you came from
yeah yeah i had a couple of close
friends from work
when you say close friends from work
there are people that you went and had
drinks with or people that you
have talked about your childhood trauma
with
um no i never really talked to anybody
about
my childhood okay and so that would be
my differentiation of friend versus
buddies at work
friend is somebody that can be i could
tell the good things to a friend is
someone i can tell
the bad things like when i violate my
values right
and a friend is something i can tell
who's hurt me in my past
and do you not have those folks like
i have my husband right you got your
yeah you've got your
your husband beyond him
yeah i actually i do have a really close
friend that i do talk
with on a regular basis what is it she
yes would she know about these things
these thoughts that you have
yeah i actually just opened up to her
about it not too long ago
gotcha so here's
here's my
here this is not for what it's worth
okay
um having intrusive thoughts
is it happens to everybody okay
especially especially i walk through
several things here
folks with with sexual abuse physical
abuse emotional boost
from childhood folks with no
friends or with a small community and
a perceived burdensomeness and this
means
i bring a room down when i hang out with
folks or i'm not going to tell them it's
just going to ruin their day
and people begin to feel like they are a
burden to other folks
and you'll see this with kids you'll see
this with you know adults like
my kids would be better off without me
my husband would just be better off
if or i'm so exhausted and worn out and
it would be better if fill in the blank
right um then there becomes this
escalating thoughts right so
my favorite dr joyner who's my favorite
suicide researcher
talks about practice and it can be
risky behaviors it can be cutting it can
be speeding a car
and peeling out just before something
bad happens
and it can also be an escalation of
practicing thoughts right
so it goes from man if i was just not
here
to i'm holding this knife i could jest
right
which turns into i'm just gonna cut
myself a little bit which turns into
oh man that relieved some pain i'm gonna
cut myself again which
is an escalation right so all those
things it would tell me
is this you've got a little girl
you have a little you said that right
little girl yeah
okay you would be somebody that i would
say if you were my friend hanging out at
my house and we're just sitting on the
front porch having barbecue and your
husband's over my wife's over and we're
cooking hanging out
and you told me what you just told me i
would tell you
you need to go see somebody you need to
go talk to a counselor
who you're going to be plugged in with
for the long haul and they're going to
really frustrate you
they're going to annoy you they're going
to drive you bananas
but they're also going to teach you some
new tools on
how to handle these thoughts if and when
they begin to increase
because my guess is these thoughts are
one of several hard coping strategies
what's something else that
you how you process things how you
interact with the world that you don't
tell other people
i know they're there i get
i just i shut people out like sometimes
i'll intentionally
get angry with my husband over silly
things
to avoid talking about other things that
are bothering me why do you do that
because i i just i just don't want to
talk about
some things and i feel like you just
wouldn't understand because we come from
very different backgrounds
and give me an example of something that
he wants to talk about that you just
you bail out on i don't want to talk
about
well sometimes when i when i am having
like some of those
those suicide or suicidal thoughts
and he asks he's like hey what's wrong
and i'm like nothing
because like i just don't want him to
worry i don't want him to
go to work and then thinking that he's
going to come home to a dead wife
right i just don't want him to worry
about that because they're not
his problems and so when he
looked you in the eye and said i do they
became
his problems and he will go to work
and he will worry about you and he will
develop scenarios and then he'll try to
solve those scenarios that may or may
not be accurate
and over time his attempts to re-bridge
that
gap that connection that that
disconnection that he feels from you
is going to get harder and wider does
that make sense
yeah and so i know you were trying to
take care of the people around you
that's what i would mean by perceived
burdensomeness these aren't his problems
these are mine i'm just going to sit on
them and be quiet
and you got a guy that told the universe
i'm going to be with you forever
and you are don't want to put stuff in
his backpack that he's got to carry to
work with him
right that's the perceived
burdensomeness
that's what i would tell you yes you
were walking down
a like a path in the woods and i don't
like the direction that you're heading
does that make sense
and you are too smart and you are too
lovely of a mom
and a wife to not value yourself in the
way that that little girl does the way
your husband does and the way other
people
would if you would let them in
who hurt you as a kid
i was a grandfather okay
did mom and dad know did they go to war
on your behalf do they cover it up how
are they involved
they covered it up okay so here's what
you got in your heart
and more specifically in the tiny little
part of your brain that's now spidered
across your entire
neurology is the most
important thing to you as a child is the
safety
that comes from your parents
relationship extended to your
grandparents
and that relationship was severed at a
young young age
it's a fireplace right and
what your brain knows is if you get too
close
to somebody else they're going to hurt
you too
and it would rather make sure you avoid
that close connection that you should
have got from them
it wants you to avoid it because man
we're not going through that again that
hurt and we will never do that again
and so you end up with a
man you love your husband don't you yeah
he's a safe guy to you absolutely
yeah he's not fully in though is he
no
what about that baby girl
what about her like you love her too
right oh yes of course
does it freak you out or make you whole
at how much he loves you
or how much he needs you
kind of freaks me out
no because like i do like you were
saying like i often think that
she would be better off like if she had
another mom
okay so victoria she wouldn't be
she's best off with you
and as i'm saying that if your first
impulse your first thought is
yeah you don't know me or
whatever if that's your first thought i
want you to hear me say
you need to go talk to somebody
will you promise me that you will
i was afraid you were going to say that
yes i promise here's who deserves it in
this order
number one you you've been carrying too
much crap
in your backpack and your heart for way
too long
and i want you to sit with somebody who
over a period of time
and hey you got a lot of junk back there
it's gonna take a season
okay and
over time you will walk taller and you
will walk
stronger than you even knew you were
capable of
you've heard me use that analogy bricks
in your backpack what you don't realize
is when they start taking those bricks
out when you start processing those and
feeling those
and then taking them out and setting
them down you don't realize how strong
you've become
carrying them around and suddenly when
those things aren't in your backpack
anymore
you realize i am a force to be reckoned
with in this world
and you find a strength that you didn't
know you had because somebody else had
dropped cinder blocks in your back
listen to me your granddad shouldn't
have done that
and your mom and dad shouldn't have let
that crap happen
and you deserved somebody to go to war
on your behalf and they didn't and i'm
so sorry
and now you've got a husband who loves
you
he doesn't even know how because he's
trying
you got a baby girl that's dependent on
you and you're
a extraordinary woman here in my
hometown who's worth being well
and the beautiful thing that i can tell
you about nashville
is there's some world-class all-star
folks that can walk alongside this with
you
if you'll let them
and so i'll ask you again you promise
you'll go see somebody
yes okay i promise will you bring your
husband
into this let him listen to this episode
and in fact it's this
there's usually delay here we'll see if
we can get you an earlier cut okay as
soon as we can
and this will give you an entry point to
talk with him okay
okay and i want you to know that your
bravery today
there are going to be thousands if not
tens of thousands of people
listening to this who have those
intrusive thoughts they just
hush them away they don't want to burden
their wife with them they don't want to
burden their
their best friend with them so they just
sit on them and sit on them
and they escalate and they get tougher
and they get tougher
and the voices get louder and louder and
as your daughter gets closer and closer
to the age you were
when the crap happened to you as a kid
starts
those voices will get louder and louder
and so by you taking the first step that
i'm making the call i'm so proud of you
the next step that i want you to do
today is to reach out to somebody
and i want you to not just go once and
be like oh they sucked it
go again and then i want you to go again
and i want you to go again
i want you to start that conversation
with
i'm having suicidal thoughts i'm not
going to hurt myself i don't have a plan
i have no imminent danger
i'm a childhood abuse survivor
my parents didn't step up when they
should have i've got a one-year-old
daughter i got a husband who loves me
i need to learn how to let this stuff i
need to be able to set it down
i need to heal and i need to learn some
new tools
and if they say well you know you need
to have a warm bath walk out
walk out smile say bye felicia i'm out
and then walk out and then go to the
next
and i promise you there's some great
folks here in this city i've met with
them myself
right thank you so much for that call
anybody out there
anybody out there if you are thinking
about hurting yourself
if you're thinking my husband my wife my
kids
my work would be better off with me not
here
even if it's not an immediate emergency
i want you to call the national suicide
prevention lifeline
1-800-273-8255
or you can text the crisis line you can
text home
to 741-741 that's not a
ramsay-affiliated
group it doesn't have anything to do
with us this is a national hotline for
folks who
are thinking i'm gonna hurt myself today
right i'm gonna take my life today i'm
gonna
attempt to step out today
text home to 741-741 24 hours a day
seven days a week please and if somebody
in your world
says man i think i hurt myself get them
the help that they need
call on the calvary if you got to we are
all in this one together
all of us are in this together and we're
going to heal together too
as couples as friends as communities as
a country
thank you for being brave victoria i
appreciate it let us know how those that
first session goes and we'll check in
with you
all right so let's go let's take one
more call let's go to lily
in dallas texas lily what's going on
hey dr john um so i have been with my
boyfriend
for two years about two years now and we
have a one-year-old
and he is a military vet um
and i feel like i'm putting too much
pressure on him
um he is struggling with ptsd
and he had a breakdown around the texas
ice storm
uh we had a very rough few days where we
didn't know
if we were gonna make it out um if he
was going to be okay
um and i feel like i'm the one that's
been putting
you know that extra pressure that's
maybe taking him to that tipping point
um and i just don't know i want him to
know he is loved
by not only myself but my son
yeah and that he has so when you say you
have a reason
to keep going yeah
well man thank you for loving your
husband when you when you
say that you're putting extra pressure
on him and that you're the cause of his
breaking point what do you mean
so i'm a first-time mom so
this is my first go around so i feel
like
you know i want the best for my son
so i want you know us to focus on
getting our first home
i want us to you know be stable
financially i know for some time it was
the vehicle so i
my vehicle i gave to him and i wanted a
bigger vehicle for
my son so i put that extra pressure on
him um
so it's just it's been a lot like i feel
like you know
he works a lot he works very hard but
i'm you know i'm with my son 24 7. i
also work from home
so i feel like sometimes i want that
extra help yeah for sure
where does your picture of this perfect
set up for your one-year-old son come
from
so here i guess so here's what and i'll
tell you like so i'm asking the question
from this
um my wife drives a 2010 prius
that we shove two kids into they can't
even fix
my son's humongous i drive an 06 truck
with 150 000 miles on it
and they just had to be in the shop i
mean
so and we've got an old house and we've
had to rent a few houses here and there
and we've had
my kids are resilient and they love life
and they are up for wild adventures and
my son asked the other day hey daddy no
matter what please don't ever move me
again i just want to be wherever we're
at
right here right so i ask you that to
tell you i have
my son has moved more since he's 10 than
i did i think
i was like 30 or something where are you
getting this picture that we have to
have this car
this house this set of furniture this
environment
or there's something that's going to
happen to our kid where's that narrative
coming from
the instability i had growing up ah
okay look at you wisely you come from
right we both come from broken
homes yep um we both come from
instability with and
we see you know as you grow you realize
how unstable things are
and you start seeing it from a bigger
picture but when you're you're
young you don't know you only see what
you hear yeah or like what's happening
at that moment
and so a lot of it comes from that
instability that i had so i went to
multiple schools there was never
consistency it was
it was a lot of turmoil within our
household um
so it was a lot and i guess that now
that i'm a mom
it's like you want everything not so
much as
better right you just want that
stability for your child
and so can i tell you a significant
temptation
is to to take that sort of instability
and to find it in stuff
and when you try to find stability and
stuff
you inherently start that cycle all over
again
does that make sense what i'm saying yes
so you moved around a lot did your
parents get divorced or was there abuse
fighting in the home growing up uh
so there was abuse there was fighting uh
there was divorce
and i as soon as i could leave i left
there you go okay so you
know what growing up you got ptsd tube i
mean ptsd too by the way
okay you're both trauma survivors and
yours is more long-term and acute and
his may be
i mean yours is more long-term and
cumulative his is a cute yours is
probably cute too you probably saw some
stuff that no little kid should see is
that fair
yes yeah and so some people escape
that with addiction some people escape
that with relationships
some people escape that with
i'll be damned this is going to look
like this
i've got a picture of something in my
head and i will make sure
everything's in order in place because
this is what
stability looks like does that sound
right
yes okay anything
less than that is feels like a slippery
slope towards what you had and
unfortunately the way we have to get to
those pictures
is by complaining poking prodding
continuing to fight because those are
the only tools we have that's the only
tools you learned
and so you're trying to build a new home
with the same tools does that make sense
yes
and what's gonna happen is you're gonna
end up building the same house over
again
and what happens with veterans
especially is they learn a whole new set
of tools
they get they get rebuilt with a new set
of tools right
and they have to learn how to not apply
those
sets of tools everywhere especially in
their civilian life
especially in their marriages especially
in their parenting
and now you and your husband have a
dance
and as you've seen this dance doesn't
end well right
no it doesn't so before we get to him
here's what i want to challenge you to
do
i'd love for you is he a good dad oh yes
is he a good husband besides the fact
that he's a veteran with ptsd and he
does military e-things
does he love you like crazy wear his
combat boots oh geez
does he wear his combat boots to mow the
yard in shorts combat boots
yes oh come on guys come on
i'm staring at a veteran right now yeah
short shorts combat boots out in the
lobby
he's smiling he's like yep guilty he
does doesn't he
yes and tell me that i'm you know tell
me that
that man would set the world on fire for
you too wouldn't he
yes he would somebody i i woe the day
somebody would mouth off to you in a
public place with him there right
yes i feel like it would be both of us
he he would smile on the way to jail
right because
right so hey here's the thing here's
what's beautiful
you're both coming from a place where
y'all are tethered into one another
so now it's not about hey i don't love
her it's not about i don't love him
this is about we love each other so
fierce and we keep
opening our tool bags and all we have is
like a screwdriver and a hammer
and we're trying to saw wood with a
hammer and we're trying to roof
the house with a screwdriver and all
that means is y'all just got to
double down on getting some new tools
and that's going to start with both of
you recognizing that you come from
a really traumatic childhood that that
little girl
that little lily has gotta heal from
because she's gonna keep standing watch
to make sure nobody gets to lily's heart
nobody because we know what happens when
someone gets in your heart they can hurt
you
and he has seen stuff that people are
not supposed to see
and he's going to make sure that will
not get to my wife that will not get to
my baby
and he'll see it everywhere and then all
of a sudden
a state's electric grid goes out right
and then it becomes
real right and then you saw what happens
when it becomes real
was that scary for the whole house oh
yes
yeah it was it was it's one of those
where you don't want
you don't want to expose your child to
see even as young as
a year old yeah but you know life kind
of happens and you you can't
there's no way to filter that that's
right so i want to tell you
in a used honda civic your baby's going
to be great
in a old 97 camry with 300 000 miles it
gets you where i need to go
for a couple of years while you all pay
off your debts and while you get on your
feet
financially your baby's gonna be fine
you're gonna be embarrassed but you're
not dating anymore anyway you got the
guy
right what do you care right and
you're gonna be great mom and your
baby's gonna have a great life
in a used uh bassinet
and with towels from walmart
and your husband's going to need to go
through a season of of getting well
and that's hard and that starts with you
look at him in the eye say i love you
baby
and i've put a lot of pressure on us to
accumulate stuff because i had this
perfect
vision picture in my head of what my of
what life had to be
and i realized man i was trying to
squeeze squeeze
all of the joy and love and excitement
and adventure out of this family
in pursuit of something stuff
and i want you to tell them i'm gonna
you lily are gonna do the hard work of
going to meet with somebody to talk
about your childhood
and that you were gonna be the power you
made brave step powerful step number one
when you got out of that house
power powerful brave step number two is
you are gonna
face turn and face that generational
trauma you're gonna stare that forest
fire in the face
and say not my family not my baby not my
husband
and this one though you can't fight with
fists and you can't fight with guns you
got to fight it with
vulnerability humility
tears learning new skills
and for him he showed you he's
struggling your husband is he's not he's
not doing great
is he still in or has he gotten out so
he's
out um do you still y'all still have
tricare access
i'm sorry do y'all still have access to
tricare
uh no no okay no i want
go ahead i'm sorry the so the
the i think this the struggle that he's
facing is you know you're right the
military restructures
its soldiers right you become a soldier
yeah um and then whenever
you are deployed you know you go on your
missions you you know you do everything
that you're told to do
you're told what to do in the morning
you're told what to do in the evening
and you have all of your days planned
out and you have some form of
you you create a family within your
barracks you know
you have to then once everything's done
you're thanked and your throat is thrown
back into civilian
life and you don't know you know you're
not you know it's it's like you're told
you're taught to make a bomb but you
can't put that down on your resume
right it's like um that's that
transition so i feel like it went from
i'm a soldier
i'm back to being a civilian i have a
partner now in life
and now i'm a dad and here's what's
beautiful about that
it doesn't sound beautiful but it is
here's why he learned how to do those
things
and that means he can learn he can learn
how to experience home life and it's a
process and it's something you go
through
and there's a number of veterans
resource services there
in texas there's a number of national
veterans resource services all over the
country
there are groups that meet in the
evenings there are groups that meet in
the mornings
he learned how to go be a soldier
and he learned how to create family
inside of barracks overseas
and he learned that when he came home
he's got to do things differently
and he can learn to love you guys the
way he wants to and the way you all
deserve
the same way as you can learn
how to love to so i want you both to
commit
to getting the help that you need either
together by yourself at some point
you're going to do this together because
you're going to learn new skills
together
you're both coming from trauma you're
both going to heal from trauma and
you're both going to create a new family
legacy together
and it starts with your bravery and
vulnerability for your call lily thank
you so much
to your husband if he's listening to
this i want to thank you for your
service i want to thank you for what you
put your heart and mind through
and i want you to know that this entire
community is around you even when it
feels like we're not
and there is healing and learning on the
other side of this
lily's gonna walk with you brother and
you're gonna walk with him thank you so
much
all right let's um as we wrap up today's
show
let's do
you know what let's don't do any lyrics
today i'm going to end it with this
i'm looking here at the camera and if
you're just listening to this
listen to me close every single one of
these callers today
has been faced with something that they
didn't ask for they didn't sign up for
or maybe they did a little bit it just
came to them right
don't be alone don't live your life by
yourself reach out to other people
don't be don't ever
look in the mirror and think you're not
worth being loved you are
you are worth getting well you're worth
being loved and if you've got people in
your sphere if you're listening to this
and this isn't you
and you know people are hurting i want
you to reach out to them today
let them know you're loved and i got
your six
this has been the dr john deloney show